why do you look like a bear what is this
the raccoon suit or also known as the
Tanooki Suit is my personal favorite fly
around
he's an adorable raccoon huh you get the
right power up and you can fly you get a
different one you might end up in a cat
suit
the cat seat is fantastic he looks
adorable
like reflexes and sharp claws
but looks like adorable character that
you just want to squeeze me yeah
huh
the Superstar makes you Unstoppable it's
like the best possible thing you want
this getting that power up in the video
game was always the most satisfying
experience the whole movie you're just
like it's Gotta happen
it's gonna blow your mind one of the
great things about Nintendo especially
Mario Brother games is that they're made
for people of all skill levels all ages
no matter how good you are at Super
Mario Brothers you get the Superstar for
15 seconds you are the best player in
the world
it's like I'm terrible at this game but
not for 15 seconds it was not terrible
at the game well you were you were
terrible at one point
I don't know about that okay
[Music]